why we had started sitting on would be
secret thank you for the introduction so
yeah thanks everyone for coming to my
talk and thanks to the organizers for
inviting me and today I'll be talking
about max effect with linear programs
surely Adam strikes back and this is
based on joint work with Ryan O'Donnell
and at a high level the point of view
that I'm coming from is is optimization
so many times in optimization we're
interested in optimizing over some
complicated sets so here when I say said
a complicated I mean it can be
complicated in several ways like maybe
it's not convex or perhaps it's convex
but it has a very large description and
one technique that we have is relaxation
so context relaxation so this means we
take our complicated set and we relax it
and possibly lift it into higher
dimension so we take it and we embed it
into some convex set and now in this
convex set we can optimize efficiently
okay but because we took this convex
relaxation there is a loss of accuracy
right so if this is kind of the
directions we were trying to optimize in
here this is the true optimum point and
you can see in the relaxation that we
get a different point with a possibly
larger value if it's a maximization
problem and so what we want to do is we
want to understand how much the
relaxation in the cost s so the goal is
to quantify the accuracy and in
particular as a function of the
relaxation size so both the dimension
that we go to and the complexity of the
description of a relaxation okay so some
popular nice steps include linear
programming so here we are maximizing
over the positive orth and subject to
linear inequality constraints another
popular type of nice that is is semi
definite programming so here we're
optimizing over the PSD cone again
subject to two linear constraints and
yet another extension of these is a
hyperbolic
programming in general but but today
lp's and STPs are going to be the stars
of our show in part because these are
the
the most well studied in the context of
discrete optimization and what we want
understand that we want to understand
the relative power of LPS and STPs so
both of these are hyperbolic cones
that's the connection to today's I mean
to this workshop so as a positive or
thent
is the hypervelocity cone of the
polynomial product sorry in the
direction the one sector so and then the
the kasey kahne
is that the it would be kind of the
determinant of X in the direction of the
identity right and and the pc cohn can
can be used to capture linear programs
and in general pretty dramatic
separations are known in the in this
power of LPS vs. SCPs so our goal is to
quantify accuracy in the function of
relaxation size and it's known that if
you want to capture semi definite
programs in general you need exponential
size linear programs right so so there
are scps that have size polynomial in n
over n by n matrices so that you need if
you want to get a constant approximation
factor to this spectrum Heatran you need
a linear program of size at least
exponential okay or if you're a fluent
in extended formulations that are
spectra Hedra
they have extension complexity n plus 1
over F CPS and extension complexity
exponential over L fees so so here we
see this dramatic separation and and the
question is how does this separation
play out for classical optimization
problems and is there some way to
parameterize the the kind of semi
definite programs and linear programs in
order to understand what this
relationship should be yeah the sense of
containment of the saleable sets or in
the objective values I contain it a very
people
okay good and I guess at tomorrow we'll
hear from from Nick about the question
of getting general hyperbola C cones in
terms of semi definite programming some
sense - Nick stop tomorrow okay so so
the problem that I'm gonna want to focus
on is maximum cut so in max cut I have a
input graph and the objective is to
output the maximum fraction of edge cut
over any partition so I'm trying to find
a partition that maximizes the number of
cut edges for example in this graph I'm
trying to I mean this is one partition I
can think of assigning positive one to
one side of the partition and negative
one to the other
all right and I can express this
optimization objective in terms of this
following integer program so I'm taking
the sum over all edges that the average
over all edges of half times one minus X
I times XJ where X is our sign so this
is going to be 1 if the vertices are on
opposite sides of the cut and 0 if
they're on the same side of the cut this
is just the fraction of edges cut
generally computing max cut is np-hard
so I guess no talk about max heads
complete without seeing this fact um but
now what I want to do is I want to
understand how well can i approximate
the maximum cut affected ok and what I
want is I went to a relaxation that
produces an upper bound on the value of
the maximum cut and how do I measure the
quality of this bound well I just I
measure it in terms of the approximation
ratio so I take the true maximum cut
value and I divide it by this upper
bound this is going to be some number in
the range of half to one right so one
means I perfectly approximated the value
of that the maximal cut and half is the
worst possible approximation factor this
is just because in any graph I can cut
at least half of the edges
so it never gets worse than half okay so
one of the most famous semi-definite
programming
results is that the following basic
scientific program approximates Mexico
well so if I take the integer program
that I had on the previous slide and
instead of requiring that my variables
be on the on the hypercube I replaced
every variable with a with a unit vector
and I'll pies over with graham matrices
of these vectors with with a norm one
then I get semi definite programming
relaxation of the following form and the
following dual formulation okay and the
the upper bound I would output is just I
would output the value of this
optimization problem over the gray
matrices so theorem due to Goins and
wounds and is that the this
approximation ratio is at least point
eight seven eight okay so so
significantly better than the worst that
you can do at half it turns out that
assuming the unique games conjecture so
a complexity theoretic assumption this
is the best approximation factor you can
get in polynomial time
okay so semi definite programs are
optimal assuming the unique games
conjecture actually if you're in the
case when the maximum craft has value
close to half then you can do even
better with a semi definite programming
relaxation so you can actually certify
close to half so so for graphs with
small maximum cuts you can get a
approximation refactor that's close to
one
all right so that's a true for STPs but
if we look at at the basic semi-definite
programming program what's what's it
doing it's using spectral properties of
the adjacency matrix so if it's d is the
diagonal matrix with the degrees on the
diagonal and is the adjacency matrix
then if you look at the dual formulation
of the FCP that the value that will
output is it will output the minimum
over diagonal matrices of trace 0 of
some scaling factor times the maximum
eigen value of the degree matrix minus
the adjacency matrix plus u so it
optimizes over such to use so it's a
very spectral relaxation okay and the
question is is special information
necessary right so generally speaking in
order for LPS to capture spectral
information accurately we need
exponential size elfies and the question
is do we really need to have exponential
size linear programs in order to get get
a good approximation ratio
okay so linear programming on station so
the conventional wisdom is essentially
that lp's are not very good at max catch
right so when you teach undergrads or or
beginning grad students about linear
programming you show them some nice
examples where linear programming works
really well and then what you do is you
say okay now try to write down a
relaxation for max that haha like you
can't do it you know they all have
factors of 2 okay this is definitely how
I was taught about linear programming
anyway um but actually I mean beyond
just this uh this exercise that you give
this under guys there's a good reason
for this so I'm going to kind of explain
in sort of a backwards chronological
order why but it makes a little bit more
sense um so here's a theorem a
combination of basically two theorems do
two Chinle raghavendran story and then
later Kothari at Mecca and Ragavendra
that shirali adams is the best possible
LP for max crap now okay what strongly
I'll say more later but essentially
shirali items is a family of linear
programming relaxations that allow you
to start with some basic linear
programming relaxation and then
systematically strengthen it by adding
variables and constraints so going to
higher and higher dimensional
constraints to get tighter and tighter
realizations okay so every level of the
shirali items hierarchy you get a LP of
different-sized okay and at level D or
the relaxation or size end of the Dean
great so basically what what was proven
this is this is the statement of Chen
lyric vendor and starter and Qatari
micro commander the statement is a
little bit more complicated but
basically what what it was shown is it
if there's any linear program of size at
most n to the D with approximation ratio
at least row and if you take level to D
shirali items which has size n to the 2d
you get at least as good an
approximation factor so if you don't
care about things like quadratic factors
in the size of LP then surely items is
basically the best selfie that you can
have
and then coupled with this there are
strong lower bounds for sure all the
items so in 2007 in de la Vega and
Mathieu proved that for any constant
number of rounds of Charlie Adams
there's a sequence of graphs that gets
appropriate word Charlie on get
approximation and most half okay I have
plus epsilon for cost Epsilon so so
constant size Charlie Adams or constant
round Charlie items polynomial size
Rollins do better thing than huh and
then significant strengthening of this
theorem came a couple years later due to
tracker I'm a cryogenic Iron Chef so
essentially what they showed is that
even if you take shirali items at degree
and to the delta 4 delta a fixed
constant you can't get the person ratio
better than half right so even
sub-exponential size lp's can't certify
better than half in general at least
already we have a sub exponential
separation between the performance of
the SDP
of polynomial size and and lp's okay
and one thing about this proof is that
if you look at it it doesn't clearly hit
the natural barrier like it's not clear
why subjects potential size should be
the correct answer okay and you think
well we know of cases where there's a
truly exponential separation between
lp's and STPs right so the question is
is there a truly exponential separation
between LPS and STPs for max cuts that
is can we prove a linear round or linear
degree sure all the atoms lower bound
for max cuts even for this sequence of
graphs maybe okay so that's one one
question motivator question here's
another motivation of my secret
motivation is trying to understand
current technology so um in in 2016
brock it's all including sam here showed
a new technique for they introduced a
new technique for proving some by
definite programming lower bounds so
this this technique is called pseudo
calibration and they used it in the
context of plane to the clique and
without getting into
let me just say that stewed elaboration
in the high level is a technique for
proving SCP lower bounds using
statistical similarity of two
distributions with different
optimization and values so for example
if you look at the maximum clique
problem over two graphs the the set of
just random uniformly random grass
versus uniformly random graphs where
I've planted the cake leak it's for some
statistics these are statistically
similar okay and because of this
statistical similarity you are able to
prove FCP lower bounds just basically by
showing a feasible FCP solution for a
specific relaxation that has too large
or an optimization value so you show an
integral yeah and this is a great
technique one of the nice things about
it is it's very general so we know also
that it works for for constraint
satisfaction problems such as case
actually this is in hindsight if you
look at the the constraint satisfaction
problem lower bounds from the past it
turns out that they to execute this
formula without having known about it so
that's really cool and then for a couple
of other problems we can also show lower
bounds using this technique and probably
for many optimization problems it an
average case in statistical up the
relation problems you could apply the
same technique the problem is it's very
difficult to show that the FCP solution
that the pseudo calibration technique
proposes is positive semi-definite right
so so all of the linear constraints are
pretty easy to enforce but then the
positive semi-definite in this step is
is quite difficult and what better way
to ignore the positive semi-definite
least concern than to consider LP is
instead right so that's that was the the
secret motivation for thinking about
this question for example you can ask
can you prove that if you take G and one
over N to the point nine nine so I heard
a training arena breath with average
degree into the point O one hit a degree
n to the point one shirali atoms
relaxation won't be able to get
approximation ratio better than house
right this is because in some sense if
you look at n 2.01 neighbor no random
vertices in the graph
they will look like completely unrelated
to each other you know it'll be a tree
or it'll be just a completely random set
and so this is some kind of statistical
similarity between graphs with large max
depth values and and subsets of these
graphs right so this is this was kind of
that though at the outset of this
project how would this question compare
with what
CMM fruit so CMM are essentially
considering random graphs with constant
average degree and this is slightly
denser graphs like small polynomial
average yeah okay so so this was this
was a kind of a motivating um but it
turns out that instead of proving rubber
bands what we prove is an upper bound
okay so so surprised so suppose that I
have a graph where the random walk
transition matrix has eigenvalues that
are bounded by some parameter 1 over
square root Delta okay there's going to
be a reason why I said it this way that
will become apparent in a second so what
we then show is that if you take
exponential in log n over log Delta
round of shirali items then you can get
an approximation ratio that's like 1
minus to the K so so a good
approximation ratio in this background
so let me instantiate this with a
specific example so say that I have a
random graph with degree order Delta or
average degree order Delta okay then
this condition will hold with high
probability and then if for example
Delta is like n to the point O 1 as
would be in this case then constant
level shirali items will achieve
approximation ratio at least 0.99 right
so this means polynomial size of peas
stirred if I get approximation ratio
close to 1 for random graphs with with
polynomial every 2 degrees okay so this
is surprising I mean already a goal
number two is wrong right so so LP is do
pretty well for random graphs
of polynomial average degree this is a
to me this came as a big surprise
so even bigger surprises the previous
lower bounds are in some sense tight so
if you look at the the graphs that the
track Rama Koch at my fire to have lower
bounds we're using basically they were
using random Delta regular graphs where
Delta is a constant okay and there's a
number of rounds that they prove a lower
bound for it's something like
exponential in log n over log Delta at
where there's a constant out front here
right so so if you take log n over log
Delta or exponential in log n over log
Delta time some constant around the
approximation ratio is at most a half
but then we show that if you take a
larger constant here then you can get a
proximation ratio close to one alright
so so the previous lower bounds are
tight as a function of the degree yeah
what's the value of the next so in in
these graphs of the value of the match
head is going to be something like 1/2
plus 1 over square root Delta I mean I
guess order
okay so the point is that that number is
small enough so yeah
this number we can never take this
number to be so small that are so large
that the answer will be wrong but yeah
it's Monica that's not true and we can
and we can approach the truth like by
taking more arounds yeah okay great so
so I think that's a that's a big
surprise and now now what you can say is
okay still I want to know if there are
graphs where linear in many rounds of
Sharlee items won't certify good bounds
where it where the approximation reach
it will be close to half and the answer
is that maybe such graphs to this but
but it doesn't seem like it's these
graphs right because I mean there's some
question about you know if there's a
specific Delta like such that you know I
mean there's an issue of the constants
out front here right this one needs to
be careful with but but yeah but it
seems like these these random regular
graphs are not good candidates for
showing exponential round lower bounds
for sure all the atoms
okay yeah so basically that would apply
you can get a fetus yeah yeah you need
this you need this suturing on it's
air-conditioned or so so so the
requirement is that the eigenvalues of
the grafts are founded Benson Tottenham
cops they don't have to be dense I mean
so so so notice that even if the graph
is sparse then this is saying this is
giving a stomach's potential sighs LP
upper bound right so so the results the
result applies regardless of the graph
being that's or not any this is just the
around but in order to get a polynomial
size help even the graph has to be a
little bit dense like but it doesn't
have to be super dense I mean just
polynomial
not at the 2nd somehow that result is
this the degrees and this does implying
is that ugly loan or this sucker the
algorithm yourself that this is implying
is always weaker than the semi-definite
program of size 2 or a size polynomial
is degree 2 right so so the LP is never
going to be better than the SDP this
will not get you better than the
eigenvalue bound that you would just get
with a cheerio spectral relaxation so
algorithmically
this isn't giving you faster algorithms
for form X guys this is just I mean the
the thing about this result is it's
really a comparison between lp's and
STPs and it's showing that that the
separation that we previously thought
was very dramatic like exponential is
not so dramatic at least under this
pseudo inverse condition on the on the
graph so you know you think there should
be an exponential separation between
help ease and FCPS in some cases there
is but this is not one of those cases
max tucked in in graphs with bounded
eigenvalues you have a sub exponential
most us have exponential separation
between
okay yeah good great question so okay
great so so so in fact yeah these
previous lower bands are tight and it's
possible that subjects financial LPS can
certify non-trivial upper bounds on
Mexico in in any graph right so if you
want an exponential lower bound for MX
that should come from a different family
of graphs
yeah another thing that's that's just
surprising I mean I guess I have said
this a couple of times with let me just
say again so here I have some spectral
condition on the adjacency matrix of my
graph and from this I get the LP has
non-trivial performance it's pretty
surprising that the LP is managing to
capture some special property of the
graph I mean to use that in order to
certify upper bounds right so I think
all right this is pretty strange and I
guess understanding this better it would
be nice oh yeah so is this this one over
Delta if you we could this can you get
some does it degrade nicely or you
really need the learners oh I mean I
just chose that ain't here there's a log
dumper so okay so really any bound on I
think I may have no you give you
something yeah yeah yeah I mean I mean
just some parameter but I just I just
chose it because I because it yeah
because of the degree yeah okay okay
great and let me also say that this
isn't only true for max fat so we can
get similar results for boolean
constraint satisfaction problems and
also for I mean this isn't this isn't in
the in the write-up on line but with
small modification you can get similar
results for vertex cover and independent
second and clean so it really seems like
this is a more general phenomenon for
for optimization over the hypercube yeah
Specter leak-tight problems like sparse
ice-covered yeah we don't I mean first
questions got enough I'm not sure what
the with issues I mean there I would
worry about how to tie the global
constraint in but but yeah but we didn't
I mean we didn't think about this
precious path' is there
[Music]
I think I mean I think that one would
just need I mean it's clear that you
couldn't do just a small modification to
what we've already done like there would
be need to be another idea but I don't
know if there's a barrier I don't know
yeah I don't know yeah we didn't I mean
it's not it's not clear to me that
there's a barrier or no barrier but it
wouldn't it wouldn't follow easily from
what we've already done I think okay
great so so let me just say for random
constraint satisfaction problems what we
get so in random constraint satisfaction
problems say that I have a sack for
example
usually the model is that I sample are
in um formula by choosing M random
clauses
and so I let's say that this is the this
is a axis in which I increase em so what
we show is that let's let's say the K is
even what we show is that if you have at
least n to the K over 2 plus epsilon
satisfy or constraints that you sample
then an LP can certify lp's these poly
stars lp's
approximate to value well
okay and what I want to do is I want to
compare this to what semi-definite
programs can do right so in
semi-definite programs you need n to the
K over two constraints in order to
certify the the value also so this is
the regime where FCC's work
okay and this is I think this is really
interesting because a priori what I
would what I thought would be true is
that you need something like n to the K
constraints for for LPS so this is this
was a hypothesis I guess it might be
kind of small for people to see but the
lines are big enough so so the point
here we see a separation in the kind of
the more constraints that you have the
easier it is to certify upper bounds and
there's a surprisingly small difference
between what what FCPS and an LPS can do
right so so in in graphs this would
correspond to degree right there's like
and you know if you look at the
difference between a constant average
degree and a polynomial degree they
might seem very dramatic but I think if
you think about it in the constant in
the in the context of constraint
satisfaction problems it actually seems
a little bit less stringent right so so
really the the separation between a peas
and FC pieces so it's equivalent in care
of your I mean before you were doing
this from the they said your value gap
yeah that was coming correct from the
very same here what's the parameter so
so here they the equivalent thing is the
eigen value gap of the I mean you can
you can take the kind of constraint
tensor right and you can flatten it to a
matrix and that's that's where it comes
from its eigen value of this finding of
the case I what controls I've got the
the thing that controls that gap is is
the the density of this tensor yeah so
so so if the tensor isn't isn't dense
enough the eigen value will be kind of
large as a I mean when you divide by the
number of constraints and then
okay great so I guess uh yeah this is
this is just to demonstrate that again
like a surprising anti separation
between between LPS and SUVs at least if
you are properly tuning the kind of
difficulty perimeter that's all one okay
so so now at this point in the talk I
guess I will tell you the proof unless
there are more questions about the setup
okay so let me tell you the proof so the
first thing I need to do in order to
tell you the proof is to define Charlie
Adams okay so so let me just say what
Charlie and this so in Charlie Adams at
level D this is a relaxation for
optimization over the hypercube in n
dimensions what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to have n to Z variables one for
each subset of n variables of size at
most D right so I'm going to get what
I'll call the studio expectation of
every monomial of size at most e okay
and what I'll do is I'll include linear
constraints so that every subset of D
variables will specify a local
distribution over boolean assignments
right so so if I look at the moments for
any subset of D variables these are
consistent with some some actual
distribution over boolean variables so
and my claim is that I can achieve this
with an LP Y so if I have a Joint
Distribution over D Boyan variables then
I can uniquely specify D with only 2 to
the D numbers right so this is just by
writing the probability of each outcome
okay and I can if I have to do the D
numbers linear constraints can ensure
that these are just a distribution
because all I need is that the sum of
the probabilities is 1 and if the
probabilities are non-negative all right
and then the final ingredient is just to
realize that these probabilities can be
written in the monomial basis okay so so
it's enough for me to to write down the
expectation of any monomial and from
this I can I can get these probabilities
and so if I constrain the monomials this
will give me a distribution so my
variables are just going to be the kind
of pseudo expectations for every subset
of the variables and from these I can
ensure that I have a global LP solution
such that every subset of D variables
corresponds to an actual distribution so
that's degree D Sheryl Adams D is the
number of the size of the
the subsets of variables it okay the
local distribution constraints okay so
in the integer program I wanted a global
distribution over cuts over the
hypercube that maximizes the expected
fraction of cut edges okay so it's like
here I would be optimizing for a
expectation operator that specifies the
moments of this distribution and in my
relaxation I'm just going to require
that the distribution be D local alright
so so I solve for these pseudo
expectation values for okay good so yeah
and then rephrasing our theorem as long
as I have my eigen value is bounded by 1
over square root Alta then exponential
in log 1 over epsilon log n over log
Delta rounds of shirali atoms will give
will certify that the eigen value is at
most 1/2 plus Epsilon so for such graphs
the sorry not the eigen value for such
graphs the next value is if most half
plus 1 over square Delta ok will certify
as 1/2 plus epsilon for any epsilon so
this is gonna be our goal and basically
what our goal is going to be is going to
be to lower bound the expectation over
an edge in the graph of the negative of
the pseudo correlation of two variables
right so this is like the objective
value of the LP so so if ya the epsilon
can never be less than or square Kelvin
if you never be less than large birds
also because this would be less than the
true market value okay because for
animgraph sighing another velvet a
photograph that has eigen values that
are 1 over square Delta that's tight
just because of the spectral relaxation
the dara graphs would suspect about is
not anything yes yeah but we can never
get better than the spectral moment yeah
yeah
I mean I guess an exponentially many
rounds we will open um great so so the
shirali atoms at degree D value for the
graph is just the expectation over edges
in the graph of you know half times one
minus this studio correlation and we
want to prove this is the most half
times one plus epsilon so so our goal is
really just going to be two lower bound
the average pseudo correlation across an
edge
okay and how are we gonna do this we're
gonna we're gonna use make use of the
following fact so let's say that I have
any D variables in the degree D Charlie
Islands relaxation and let's say that I
have a positive semi definite matrix M a
D by D positive side of the matrix M so
here because I have at most D variables
I know that the studio expectation of
this quadratic form with M is going to
be non-negative okay and the reason is
that in an actual distribution the the
the the you know ZZ actual distribution
ZZ transpose the expectation of Z
transpose is going to be positive
semi-definite right so this is just
going to be a quadratic form an
expectation so so we have to we lower
bound it by zero I can also write this
as a linear form in the studio
expectations of the pairs right the
super correlations um and now even if I
take a expectation over subsets of D
variables at a time this will still be
true right because I'm just just by my
you know I'm summing positive number so
I'll get something negative so what our
plan is going to be is it's going to be
to choose a distribution over subsets of
at most D variables in the graph and a
specific positive semi-definite matrix M
so that from D locality we'll get the
this expected quadratic form is nonzero
okay but but by our choice of this
distribution and the choice of this
matrix we're going to get this is equal
to the expectation across an edge in the
graph of the studio correlation across
the edge plus some small constant
epsilon right so this will this will
give us our goal so you yeah if you had
wanted you put
to depend on the subsets age is that
right if we wanted we could but we
didn't do it yeah it's going to be a
fixed fixed matrix okay so this is I
mean this is just our syntactic goal
find a PSD matrix M and a distribution
over subsets of variables so that we get
this so that you know this quadratic
form gives us this value okay and then
by D locality we'll have it at the no
zero and that will give us our lower
bound great so so now let me tell you
how we're going to choose this subset of
or this distribution over subsets what
we're gonna do is we're going to use
random walks okay so you know random
walk in in a graph what I do is I just I
pick a vertex and then every step I pick
one of its neighbors and I jump to it
uniformly at random and this walk has a
stationary distribution and you know
it's it's given by this and and proof of
this is simple but I'm not gonna do it
um
and what we're going to do is we're
going to define the following
distribution over pairs of vertices in
the graph
okay so define DT to be the distribution
over pairs in the graph sample those
follows first I simple a vertex
according to the uniform measure sorry
the stationary measure and then what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to take a t step
random walk and I take the final vertex
that I'll and that to be u T okay so a
fact is that if I take d1 and I take a
pair of vertices sampled according d1
this is like a uniformly random edge in
the graph because I'm picking a vertex
according to the stationary measure and
then I'm jumping to one of the Sabres
this is a uniform hyper graph so this is
it you know just basically a calculation
okay another fact which is a little bit
less trivial but also not very difficult
is that if I take T to be something like
log n over log Delta then u 0 and E 1
are going to be close to a uniformly
random pair of vertices in the graph so
basically if I take log n over log Delta
steps of random walk I'm going to mix to
the stationery measure
up the total variation distance little
a1 this is equivalent to saying that for
any vertex in the graph say if I take
the indicator for a and I apply the the
random walk operator the power T I get
close to PI in infinity-norm or whatever
whatever you like and the proof here is
as simple as well so basically what I do
is I take this indicator for the vertex
a and I decompose it spectrally
according to the the eigenvectors of my
random walk matrix and if i take the
teeth power i'll get to the tooth karzai
you value what i can do is i can write
this as sum factor times the stationary
stationary measure but stationary
measure has eigenvalue 1 and let's say
that all of the other eigenvalues are at
most 1 over Delta so I'll get something
like this right
and here the rest I mean this is a these
are vectors other than those unit norm
so if I take T to be at least log n over
log Delta this will be a little of one
and and I'm getting really close to that
okay so so from this we get the
following in fact if I take T to be at
least log n over log Delta then you zero
and you t are distributed essentially
like independent samples from from the
stationary measure on the graph okay
this is these two facts are basically
going to be the effects it will use
so okay so know what we're doing is
we're going to choose our distribution H
according to what L call random walk
embeddings so we're going to define H to
be distribution over sub graphs of this
graph sampled as follows will sample a
kind of roots vertex u 0 according to
the stationary measure okay and then
we're going to take K independent T
steps are in and walk from from you
right so and the set of vertices that we
see is going to be the subset of D
variables that we're looking at so we're
basically embedding this spider right
it's like a you know the body of the
spider and then K legs with length T
into the input graph there's random
abetting right and my claim is that if I
take any two neighbors in this embedding
they're distributed like a uniformly
random edge in the graph just because
they're distributed according to D one
right it's because like I pick a state
by four text according to the stationary
measure and then I think one arena walks
up from it so the graph you throats you
see them or you forget that what you see
it on the graph will include every
vertex that I see in there including you
see including easier oh yeah and the
ones along the path and the ones along
with okay yeah so so yeah so the
neighbors are going to be distributed
like iid edges in the graph and the end
points the the embeddings of the end
points like u t1 vs u t2 these are going
to be like uniformly random pairs
because I picked T to be large enough so
that it's like the mixing time for the
random walk
so they'll be like like yeah like like
iid samples from from the stationary
measure
okay these are these are basically the
only Saxton on these so so for just for
the case of demonstration let's fix T to
be one right so let's say that we're in
a case where the we're walks of length
to mix so so that the endpoints of the
the star will be like uniformly funeral
symbols from stationary measure so so
what I'm doing is I'm embedding a K star
into the graph so now let's look at the
distribution that I get from or the the
expectation of the the vector Z Z
transpose where I pick my my variables
according to this embedding right so so
if I look at this I'm going to get a
block matrix of the following form in
these entries these correspond to the
correlation the pseudo correlation
between a the the kind of roots and a
child this will be like the pseudo
correlation of a uniformly random edge
in the graph but this is because walks
of length one are like uniformly random
edges in the graph so that's good
because I want I want to have my
quadratic form include the the pseudo
correlation of uniformly random edge in
the graph
the diagonals are going to be one just
because it's a boolean distribution it's
a relaxation for a boolean distribution
okay and then here for the off diagonals
which correspond to pairs of the kind of
spokes of the star these are like
uniform pairs this is the pseudo
correlation of the uniform pair in the
graph
approximately up to a small total
variation distance um and human-made
first second and assume that this
quantity is zero okay so it find it
doesn't make sense that you would have
that if you pick a uniform pair of
vertices in the graph that they have
large pseudo correlation in magnitude
one or the other but this won't be
important but just for now is saying
that it's zero so now what we can do is
we can choose a matrix M so that we can
get such an inequality and our matrix M
is going to be the following positive
semi definite matrix I'm going to take
VV transpose where
V is a vector where V 0 is 1 so V 0 a
kind of corresponds to the entry of the
of the Rift and all the other entries
are 1 over square K and now I will have
from the fact that I have D local
distributions that the expectation over
such graphs times this this matrix is
non-negative okay and if I write this
out I'll get I'll get a bunch of trim so
I have I mean
maybe I'll skip skip this kind of a over
this part but essentially I just take
the the inner product between these two
matrices and I get an expression that
looks like this so I have um Sam are you
okay so in some sense like there was
something here about M that depended on
how the random embedding looked right
because there's this special row and
column and I had to make sure that my
end up the end special row and column
lines up with this guy so I had to look
at like like which like it's not just
quite a subset H it's like like the
subset specifies who is in the middle
yeah the order the order matters yeah
yeah okay but it's not it's not the case
that I need a different M for every H
that's how I interpreted your previous
question right so yeah I know what my
previous question was not this refine
talked about now
now I'm understanding that you need to
you need to like really like I could
think of it as either picking an H with
in order or reordering the columns and
rows of M appropriately to match who it
is
yeah so that yeah the form of Emma will
depend on on the way that this star
looks thanks right and then just if I
take the quadratic form of these
matrices it's not a difficult but it's
also not an interesting calculation to
show that you'll get some some numbers
and you'll have a term here that the
depends on the average Studio
correlation across an edge in the graph
right because that comes from from these
from the first row in the first column
okay and then and then great so so now
if you simplify this expression you'll
get a lower bound on the average pseudo
correlation across an edge of negative 1
over square root K and as you take K
larger and larger this is a better and
better smaller and smaller value of
epsilon here okay so this is how we do
it and if you don't want to have the
value near be 0 what you do is you take
it slightly I mean in order to not sing
this we take a slightly more complicated
abetting so instead of looking at one
star
we look at pairs of stars independently
being in bed at the same time similar
things will happen if you look at the
expectation over the subset now
corresponding to two stars you'll get
you'll get such a matrix where you still
have entries that correspond to the
average pseudo correlation frozen edge
you have entries that are 1 and then you
have entries that are like uniformly
random pairs in the graph okay and now
you just choose a slightly more
complicated matrix M so that these these
entries will cancel with these entries
right so this is where the uniform
uniformity assumption matters or not the
informing assumption but the fact that
we chose teeth to be large enough to get
uniformly random pairs okay and we
follow the same plan and we get this
lower bound and if you want to you if
you want to make T larger than 1 what
you do is you just take instead of
taking stars you take longer arms right
so that you get you know four in and
then you know same thing will happen
you'll have a matrix uniformly random
edge in the graph uniformly random pairs
you just choose a more complicated case
T certificate but but you follow
basically the same plan and you get this
dependence right so here now the
exponent of K depends on T and basically
what you do is you choose K the number
of arms to be 1 over epsilon to the T
okay and you choose T to be log n over
log Delta and you can certify a lower
bound of of Epsilon so this is where the
expected information good-evening other
distribution of these spiders yes the
only place where spectral information is
being used is to reason about the mixing
time of random walks right and and what
you really want is you want to know what
radius you have to go in order to see
uniformly or inner pairs of vertices
yeah yeah
okay great so it's not completed because
Pablo give me angry eyes so so yeah the
conclusion is basically TLDR and graphs
with small eigenvalues small LPS consult
a scrap smaller lp's than we expected
okay and I think this leaves many
interesting questions open so one
question is can we strengthen this
result right so so for SD peas we know
that if I have a graph in which the max
cut has value close to half you can
certify that with an F CP the question
is can you do this for LPS as well using
some kind of spectral decomposition of
the graph so this would be this would be
nice to know another question is what is
the linear extension complexity of
maximum cut are there are there graphs
that certify that you really need LPS of
size exponential in order to match the
performance of an SCP
and then finally one question is how do
we compare you know LP is an S and s DPS
and general for statistical problems is
there a way to understand pseudo
calibration through the comparison
between LPS and STPs
I'm happy to chat about any of these
offline and thanks for
questions or comments so sample these
sweaters but I think they're not
accessing like a month so is there some
improvement if I get given that please
make faster so okay so I don't I don't
know I mean it depend I'm not sure if
there's some improvement but I guess
that because because the lower bounds of
CMM match ours up to contact you might
only be I mean it's possible you could
get some kind of constant factor
improvement but not really but I
yeah we didn't think about it also
just such a the key idea is that because
the walk mixes fast the pair correlation
and also local yes yes but the edge
correlation is always yes I'm not sure
if this is correct but when you have the
specter gap that you can certify some
spectral bound using some kind of sparse
and in vector Y sparse because somehow
isn't that your subset is it sub
matrices yeah so so one thing that else
is it it does seem important that you
have a like if you wanted to certify
this for a vector of norm ax worden over
the unit sphere rather than a balanced
vector of norms or done then it would be
a little bit I think there would be some
issue with scaling factor direct because
you know I mean this is this wage for
boolean vectors and and the boolean any
assumption is a little bit important
thing right you need you need that you
can do too much value for right but but
if you I mean if you do assume that you
have balanced vector than you're looking
at sparse sub vectors to certify then it
then it does work like instead of
instead of instead of it enforcing the
Sharlee items constraints what you could
do is you could enforce local PSD and s
constraints on on matrices of size D PI
D and also the diagonal being one novena
yeah
and maybe it's not that it's a sparse I
in victory but I think you're showing
that some PSD matrix has a local
decomposition bocal - lestine
factorization yeah punches as far as
matrices I think I think that's your not
more inside it seems like I mean we can
talk about us yeah yeah they're right
it's more it's um yeah yeah you may have
a dense matrix but it won't overwrite
the actors as a question is important
teams can tailor this might work if you
have only a few small idea of these
things have one bad cut
yeah I'm I guess that are you just
saying that there could be some kind of
spectral decomposition and yeah I think
that's that's true right again it
wouldn't just be the mixing time
analysis but great correlation yeah I
think I think if there's a simple I mean
I think if there's a simple way to
decompose the graph and to then choose
spiders within those parts then it would
be fine yeah but but the question is how
how simple is this decomposition going
to be in terms of this diagram again
that's what shoes
some things have been again 20 minute
break will resume 11:45